[Musique]
à saint-martin d'aba dans le loiret il
ya les boîtes à lettres des courges à 30
km de là à lui en sus casse il y a
désormais les chaises décoré à une de
plus 73 c'est ça ça fait si oui c'est la
63e chaises des corridas monsieur le
maire et son adjointe ont de quoi être
content l'opération décorer une chaise
et l'exposé a remporté un vif succès des
voix on est très fiers on a lancé ça au
moment des faits des beignets et et en
fait on a une réaction en boule de neige
quoi donc tout le monde s'élance et
c'est formidable parce que voilà quand
on est à la tête d'une commune de 400
âmes et que l'on veut attirer
l'attention
eh bien il faut avoir des idées on est
les plus petits du canton de la
communauté de communes et qu'on aime
bien se faire remarquer et donc voilà on
a eu cette idée de trouver un objet qui
permettrait à la fois de réunir la
population et de de créer l'événement un
peu
[Musique]
avec les moyens du bord les lucs d'unia
ont rivalisé d'imagination
chaises musicales ambiance vacances ou
bien un coupe du monde de football
quant à cette habitante emballé par
l'idée elle aussi a fait dans la
récupération
c'est une chaise fleurs et comme j'avais
eu un mariage très peu de temps avant
donc je décorais avec tout ce qu'il y
avait du marié
vu le succès rencontré le conseil
municipal envisage même de créer un
festival ce sera pour l'année prochaine